hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing ok
enough beating around the bush I know
I've been doing a lot of dialogue a lot
of exploring a lot of that stuff but
we're gonna get into this tent we're
gonna see what the mainstays is all
about
all right climb crosses his arms and
grunts when you approach the stage
showing til later when later yeah but
when exactly later okay jeez what the
muscly clown don't seem to want to go
you two go with what do you mean later
this extremely muscular clown seems to
be gardening the entrance to some sort
of main stage oh yeah you look it I'm a
cowpuncher I'll have you know Oh fine I
got me a ticket but I don't have no man
well that sucks
all right fine then if they don't want
me in this clown place I gotta get the F
out of here and I'm out of here
screw this all right you know where i'ma
head my head to the railroad camp
because I've been meaning to go there
for a while and I need a whoo I can't do
that so it don't matter
yeah what do we got here the manifest
destiny railroad company camp oh well I
ain't this nice out ain't this lovely
out won't be long here Oh it'll be long
all right this guy should never be put
in charge of a switch he's too busy
playing with his watch to get any work
done ask him where he got it
say that's a nice watch where'd you get
it I bought it from this gal around the
store down south ear name a Buttonwillow
Buttonwillow Mick Mick something oh yeah
I know that store yep real nice store
real nice watch all right thank you
she's not getting much track laid but
she's an expert Whistler hello you
approached the beleaguered looking man
with the tiny glasses howdy there who's
in charge of this outfit if I'm being
charitable I'd say that fellow over
there and the white has an Foreman he
points at the man next to a large pile
of rocks and if you're not he smiles
then I'd say that paperback Diddy and
over there and the absurd white hat is
the fellow you're looking for all righty
thanks hello you look sad hi you in
charge I was wondering if there's
anything I can do to help you want to
know something I love trains Oh ever
since I was a boy huge magnificent
brawling iron beasts they were magical
to be like dragons when the opportunity
arose to take on a management of the
rail line I jumped it like a shot and
you know what I learned what's that
organizing and building running one of
these operations is the most amazing
pain in the ass
never imagine you want to help
congratulations job a new Foreman I'm
going home to play with my models oh
thank you
why'd I do that well hello I'm the
foreman now I got a nice hat to go with
it I'm the boss now
well I'm now I suppose you can't be any
worse than the last clown he extends it
sounds don't talk to me about clowns
I've had many experiences with clowns
recently I don't like them names me I'm
your assistant what's the situation well
I'm sure you didn't miss seeing a giant
pile of rocks block it up half the
Servius see there's no other way around
the mountain pass so the cab reroute it
even if we already take it take months
to take any ideas well by my
calculations we could dynamite it clear
without too much trouble
problem is it will take a lot of
dynamite whole year's worth I figure we
used to keep that much on hand for
emergencies such as this one but a pack
of goblins stole it away sneaky little
varmints all right I'll get it back for
you glad to hear the goblins are holed
up over and Gustav and Gulch it's a real
rough place you might want to spend some
time getting the lay of the land home in
your fighting skills before you head
that way especially if plan to go get
him going to blazing you were discovered
a new map location Gustav and Gulch we
don't need that specific dynamite though
and you can lay your hands on and be
fine so long as there's enough of it
all right Smee well it's a good thing I
got a goblin companion right here in
Gustav and Gulch
well ghosts have been gulps look - Oh
some walk walk noises leave you down to
his sight in the sight of a goblin
chopping down a large cactus when it
sees you it waives his accent you
threatening Lea and make some angry
sounding noises that's a human person a
human person - way to going
it's my cactus that's mine and not yours
all right Jerry Derek can you deal with
this man daring the Goblin chatter back
and forth too quickly for you to follow
they share a laugh I'm the Goblin give
something to Gary then they shake hands
and the Goblin goes back to work on his
cactus what was that all about
good chat nice fellow what are you
laughing about you so tall so so tall
very funny here a guffin it to give him
but I'd ID him having what I got a
guffin what's the guff 'end oh hello
hi sir the fancily dressed goblins have
swords hi hello being a mayor welcome
now going away please what's up Gary
it's okay I will handle this Gary and
the mayor converse for a bit too quickly
for you to follow what they're saying
what'd he say he's saying okay forgiving
dynamite boom but you having to riddling
first riddling yes yes a contest game
okay let's having it the mayor clears
her throat a crazy thing having no legs
at morning and no legs after noon and
also no legs at night what is it hey
Gary not helping that would be cheating
bad bad is it a snake it's a no leg
horse isn't it it's a horse with no legs
it's a no leg horse nope this answer is
no good but it's so wrong being so wrong
well [ __ ] all right all right how about
snake nope
oh well all right then how about an egg
okay yes an egg having no legs ever
correct
well except if hatching into something
that legs having but then it's not egg
anymore whoo so who caring okay sure
next riddle you ready yeah more eating
lighter getting lighter getting shorter
living what am i a fire haha fire is not
alive oh okay whatever fine screw you
how about an egg
nope all right fine god damn it all
right yeah
Oh mayor ah okay yes I am a mayor
correct parade Hey okay one more
riddling ready okay metal thing with
little teeth in a hole turning round
entrance to my house is found where is
it in your vest pocket no good looking
there all right how about under your
welcome mat all right well how about in
in your hat no oh is it is it an egg
it's an egg
well [ __ ] that there's one doesn't have
an answer Gary
folks I'm sense into him oh hello a
goblin village how nice to introducing I
must admit Oh garel okay also finding a
key all right the key I have it here it
is you solve the riddle I got a year
supply of dynamite for
eating I'm not gonna eat it maybe I am
the foreman so I guess destiny is mine
to fulfill whatever that means right
thank you to my tonight okay I want to
go in your town oh you'd be welcome here
every time except not past here we're
standing Thanks thanks man all right
thank you well I got it for the the
thing railroad camp you want some
dynamite I got a year supply
I'll be just Scootaloo over here it's
very heavy I can't actually stand up
straight with it hey buddy yup here you
go
a year's supply good perfect this will
do the trick just fine
hang back for a bit while I get the
fellas to set up the charges you know
I'll let you do the honors smeet
consults with the other workers and they
inspect the rocks for a time eventually
one of them shrugs pushes the whole
crates of dynamite up against the rocks
and wires up a dent in air all right let
her rip we're dead
you have a longer detonator Gable nope
no worry you'll be fine just give me a
three count before you hit the plunger
so I have time to get under the truck
all right
straight good blue oh my god surveyors
didn't say anything about a crazy rock
monster quick you're the protagonist
doing something about it all right
tumblin there is a very large and very
angry looking thing guy standing there
apparently it's a little peeved at
having a year's supply of dynamite
blowing up next to its but while I was
sleeping how are you gonna handle it I'm
gonna intimidate it that's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna intimidate the hell
out of it oh yeah come on bring it
I'll show you a meaning of Cleveland or
in a geological sense I'll smash you two
pebbles boy I'll wrap you up in rocks
and paper and cut you to ribbons you
piss crap or should I say piece piece of
rock okay okay I get a cheese okay don't
you forget it
whoa you walked away into an explosion
all right well I did your job for you
well now that is a fine day's work as
I've ever seen much obliged friend will
be getting the rest of the track laid
down and head now
now here a mock out route on your map
for you in case our paths happen to
cross again
thanks but can I just ride the train got
a ticket ha just kidding cost you don't
have a seat on this train sold out sorry
boss Oh farewell the remains of your
triumphs over that crazy rock pile guy
alrighty then
welp that was fun I guess alright
nothing much to see here now
well hey Gary how's it going iron snake
has escaping westward ho
I guess wow I guess I can huh well what
have you been you come across the corpse
of a cowboy how do you know it's the
corpse of a cowboy well you see by his
outfit that he is a cowboy and you see
by his lack of flesh that is a corpse
I'll give them a proper burial
a proper burial it's the least I can do
I'm so goddamn honorable what the hell
is this place
hello what is the man's word it says
tannery it's where we used to make cow
skins in the leather ah no more
wondering why cows are so angry well you
might have a point there that is true
sounds like there's a lot of fighting
going on inside the tannery except
instead of the regular fighting sounds
you used to like shouting and gunfire
and chairs being broken over people's
backs
you're a lot of ghostly bellowing and
shrill cackling laughter sounds like a
real bad scene let's go in as you enter
the tannery the second thing you notice
is that the places have been abandoned
for years probably since the cows came
home a lot of the equipment is wrecked
and all of it covered in dust the first
thing you notice if there's a bunch of
rodeo clowns in here fighting with well
they aren't clouds exactly they're more
like possessed skins of cows that's a
little strange because you've seen
people wearing for example cow leather
chaps and you'd never seen anyone being
attacked by their own chaps maybe
there's something about the tanning
process that makes leather impervious to
possession and these cow ghosts
whatever's our untanned hides in any
case of clowns cows seem preoccupied
enough with the fighting that they
haven't noticed yet at least Oh alrighty
then why you keep keep doing your thing
dear lady
Lulla do why are there so many goddamn
clowns here the door is locked what
surprise this is well considering the
ruckus you hear on the other side of it
well I don't know why I'm here I'm gonna
get in the fight your attempt to sneak
up on the cow is assuming you're even
speaking and not just moseying over the
cows a beer all too willing to add your
face to the list of faces they hate and
turn their attention from the clowns who
jump on this opportunity to get the jump
on their ancient enemies I'm gonna join
the fracas whoa Hey look I'm fighting
with the clowns I don't like that at all
I know I actually don't like that none I
don't like that none yep I gotta get
Garrett some beef um ups because Gary
Garrett goddamn Gary you're a little
wimpy for my day sir
weapon true to form the clowns who were
on your side in that fight to betray you
damned clowns god damn it
oh you clown bastards I'm gonna be fum
up real good and you're gonna get oh
you're gonna get a load of this whap all
right well kill those clowns that's good
feels kind of strange to be fighting
alongside demonic clowns but I guess war
makes for strange bedfellows please
ignore the fact that i just used demonic
clowns and bedfellows in the same
sentence oh no no what i'm gonna do
about that door though think I gotta
kill all these guys maybe oh maybe I can
get to that thing maybe that's what I'm
looking for just let me just make my way
over here hmm let's see seeing as the
makings of a real brawl not only does
one of the clown's of a nasty look at
his eye nastier than typical I mean but
one of the possessed cowhides is
stretched on a tannic frame which makes
it chewy here somehow
all right I'll beat him up I'll join the
fracas can I beat up my clown fellows
Wow whoa
that actually hurt okay BAM okay that
guy's dead which I assume means the
clowns are gonna turn on you the clown's
turn on you after the callee yep there's
not surprising
that's it that guy hey hey hey
are we geez um sorry I'm gonna get beefy
BAM
it's done [ __ ] oh my oh well this this
actually this actually seems like it
might be bad holy [ __ ]
ha a rope oh I'm a rope yeah not that
one no god damn it that's not the one Oh
selecting bad guy oh [ __ ] I use this all
right well drop it on your head that's
good yep that that works too okay now
wampum one pull-up one more whooping
that guy's done that guy's done fur that
guy's done for BAM get out of here [ __ ]
oh and now it's just you guys I got you
I got your number BAM ha okay
calm down calm down no no I did that
varmints get a knife tannery backdoor
key okay this is what I'm looking for
hey bones how's it going the body
must've been lying here tanneries Saint
rage key Saint rage who the hell's Saint
rage man that sounds bad also I'm gonna
give myself more of this good stuff
alright that's a good level up that's
not bad unlock it
no boy oh geez this is not a good
situation to be in you quickly hide
behind some old tan hides huh
is that what they're called that there
are three clowns out of here each armed
with a nasty looking knife one of them
is licking his knife and the sound makes
you think he's literally sharpening the
blade on his tongue facing down to the
stretched ad cows and a monstrous thing
that looks like an entire cow skeleton
draped in flayed cow skin listen in I
bet you think you lot think you're real
clever breaking through the human did
you think we wouldn't follow you Moo did
you think you'd find a weapon here to
use against us all right you just trying
to escape Moo
what take that back none of them seem to
have noticed you it looks like you could
sneak two back through the door if
you're really careful I'll come back
I'll come back I'll be real careful
about my sneaks Monken let me go to the
I need to go back to dirt water real
quick because I need to get some more
supplies especially the beef Gary up
okay
oh that's right I forgot I needed a good
Stern's ranch that was like the first
place that I was supposed to go wasn't
no not the ranch not the ranch I needed
to go to the desert house that was it
oh I got a meat nugget just out in the
plains that's fine
I got a sneek stunk oh my god it's been
so long since I've been here
my sneaks nothing my way over here this
dog s contains an angry dog give them Oh
give the dog a bone with a knick-knack
patty-whack you achieve your aim the dog
begins contentedly gnawing at a human
femur good for him good for him and Dave
not good for him that I'm gonna beat up
his masters over here all right the
hinges on the Gator really Rossi if you
open it the guys insider definitely
gonna hear all right bring it on we got
the jump on him this time buddy beef up
and get ready to smack BAM oh geez these
guys are much much weaker than uh much
weaker than they should be because I
should have faced them ages ago
but yeah but yeah oh it wasn't ready for
the beef bag of ears and such desert
gang Six Gun and a black hat it's not
it's not the hard hat don't be afraid of
his hat it's not inherently bad it's
just a common style choices for bad guys
all right whatever you say is there's a
stylist black hat how's it look
oh that's a nice that's a nice hat oh
that's a nice hi oh that is a goddamn
nice hat oh man I mean general gobs hat
is real good here but oh that is a1 Oh
better than my 4 gallon hat ooh I gotta
go with that one hmm gotta go with you
oh look how cool I look oh look how I
look all right I gotta go back to town
now cuz I just got this these guys how
do you they're I'm wandering Sally howdy
Sally I'm muffler Oh
tradin care to see the wear so I'll see
the wares wandering Sally's camp oh okay
all right then back room bro I need that
I do needles need that definitely work
boots not okay
ah Jail here we go howdy what can I do
for you here's what's left of the desert
gang whoo
yeah this is certainly is a bag of
severed ears and teeth and such which
gang was this geez the house in the
desert gang I'll take your word for it
good job well didn't know I I didn't
know I was I didn't know I killed him we
was there a way to not kill him how was
that way I'm not sneaky I'm a cow punch
right punch people real hard ah goddamn
it right hot Tim kin gang for unlicensed
civil engineering and flaunting of
construction regulations unregistered
settlement north all right
go check it out black hat bandits for
horse theft in the selling counterfeit
blue last seen headed north towards the
old millinery no good can come of
criticism correct critical critical
critters millinery Mulliner e milliner e
ah i'm gonna go for these guys you have
a run-in with a more worst-smelling
snake you've ever come in your life it's
basically a cartoon stick line come to
life I gotta fight that one oh Jesus
funny snake oh I gotta give him the
shrim growth that's right BAM all right
good Gary eat this Gary's more powerful
now apparently that's that's weird
all right goin in there it's the law
skedaddle find five bandits lounging
around a big pile of half-made hats
the band is scattered like cockroaches
each shutting themselves by a different
door guess you'll have to wrangle them
individually all right then
hatch a filthy floor wears a lot of hats
all right rims all right
music this apparently was a demo model
from a player piano showroom it's only
got three songs in it they're all
different
children's versions of traditional songs
that are in the recently invented public
domain and they're all set up to play
just the first few seconds the people
who worked here must have hated it what
song do you want to set it to dial -
hang on a second I'll I'll get it there
let me just look in here ooh this door
is very locked all right
you pick the lock the remaining bandits
will Courtney if you go in there now
there take care of them first
all right yellow rose you changed the
song on the piano is that whistling you
hear
ah ah I get it I get it
is this where they're hiding J'Accuse
J'Accuse bang yeah that's right get out
of there well that's one oh I probably
could have not killed him I didn't know
well happen um but room number one is
obviously you two cues took you tuck use
bang
I got you that's two down so these all
must be clues to something I saw that I
saw that to Q's bang get out there on
three five down ah there you are
I hear you there J'Accuse bang wake up
buddy boo it's time to get up okay
there's only one more you guys left only
one more oh wait I see it one of you
guys has a different hat it's gotta be
you right J'Accuse bang ha ha ha ha I've
got all of you deal with them
Oh turn them in okay goodbye Oh would
you find them the old mill enery of
course you know bandits would be a lot
harder to find if they didn't keep
picking systematic hideouts for some
reason anyway is your word well thank
you thank you for that thank you
just whines day.i all right well goodbye
all right the Gherkin brothers for
kidnap and bringing kidnapping victims
and attempted sale of human flesh for
consumption well I seen that in for thee
of old abandoned pickle factory can't
let these dastardly criminals escaped
justice all right fine fine if that be
the way that it gonna be I'll get the
potemkin gang later oh this is haunted
is it a haunted Factory
oh all right let's see what's up feel
sudden electrical jolt as your hand
touches the doorknob Oh No you're too
late you're late for your shift
mrs. Blass is gonna be so mad she might
literally bite your head off okay well
not literally literally probably quick
get suited up you clock in and heard Lee
put on your bright green coveralls
mrs. Blass as predicted as furious late
again
you better stop taking this job for
granted you think you're gonna find a
place with a nice dormitory in a
reasonably applies comedy store like our
somewhere else with your skills haha
you're doing three shifts a day buster
get to work you're on pickle hopper duty
okay
pickle Opera Duty runs you ragged like
always keeping the hoppers filled with
the constant flow down the chutes mean
you're constantly added near sprint
because you have to manage the coop
shunts the cuke shunts to keep the
levels equal if you get uneven pickle
levels mrs. lass knows nobody knows how
she knows but she knows a whack from her
cane is the minimum you'll get damn it
damn it damn it at the end of the first
six hours shift you get a brief break
you cram a stale cheese sandwich into
your mouth while mrs. blast glares at
her pocket watch counting down three
minutes to second reigns over seconds
you have to get over the salt tank now
Oh God
managing the salt tank is in the strain
II was in some pickle operas but it's
never still a never-ending tedium the
Brian concentration has to be constantly
monitored and kept out of very specific
measurements which means constant
adjustments meanwhile you can feel your
desiccating from the haze of salt dust
that fills the room if anything in this
place kills you it's probably to be the
salt tank duty white lung is it nasty
business COFF COFF onto your own dime
and get that salinity back to normal
it's supposed to be 976 parts per
thousand how hard is that to remember
976 idiot please let me out of here you
get another under an 18 second break
before search if you spend most of it
drinking water the company doesn't
charge for water but you've heard a
rumor they're considering it banks
however get to the point please let me
out
boiler duty means shoveling coal into
the furnace a furnace that runs a giant
take a boiling vinegar it stings in here
you've tried to work with your eyes
closed but mrs. last screams if you drop
any call on the floor or if you let the
temperature get through low or too high
or just for no particular reason
at least he uses smell of boiling
vinegar in fact you can't smell anything
anymore
let me out please let me out 190° idiot
not 189 not 191 what do you think we pay
you for
you don't really miss your sense of
smell we're not coughing all the time
you don't really want anything anymore
except to die let me out let me out let
me out for the gas we finally snap out
the horrible who's the nation or
possession or whatever the hell that was
geez you can still feel the sting of
vinegar vapour in your eyes I'll let her
okay I'm in here now apparently that was
fun
ah factory allegation activation letters
all right well I'm supposing I was
supposed to remember all this cukes all
right these got to be equal huge chunk
chunk old is that even not quite oh no
not too much
oh boy Oh what are you doing you posted
ghost got it cutting can't sleep until
it's right you all right there partner
can't sleep Oh cute shunts are to be
operated by qualified personnel only
I'm pretty qualified maybe hey that's
even that's even that's even baby that's
even okay even-steven
salt horse breeds 531 was 977 I think it
was 970 something who's 970 something I
can't remember what it was all right
well this is supposed to be a hundred
and ninety something take the shovel
well I got a shovel but that's not what
I wanted add some coal blue blue it's
supposed to be one hundred and ninety
damn oh not that Rick babe
no god damn it I'm so close ah
come nineteen [ __ ] you yeah under 90 all
right we got it we got it we got it we
got it it's not right it's not right the
Vander vinegar is 190 degrees it's
finally done
thank you the ghost smiles as he fades
away a few bones hit the ground below it
rest in peace you vinegar soaked bastard
hey the gooks are even you are you done
gotta took care of the cucumber's it's
finally done thank you the ghost smiles
as he fades away a few bones at the
ground pile of bones and cucumbers weird
okay all right then well they're done ah
oh it was 976 salt-crusted skull and
that just leaves the factory activation
you got three ghosts pickles all that
work for three pickles no wonder this
place went out of business
well okay then did I did I guns it am I
done did I do that did I do it his ghost
Wow Wow they why would you make
something like you could have sworn
there was an empty dusty room you could
have sworn there was with vinegar tank
and a boiler in there why would you make
something like that up you know what I
just don't know I really don't know I
really don't know all righty then those
doubt bazaar okay all right anyway
baddies all the time I got for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching I don't know why we went on a
ghostly pickle adventure but frankly I
don't know if I want to know so thank
you again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]